avec céline noémie à béatrice est
également équipé puis bravo pour votre
nomination
bon gars de mémoire je crois 10
nominations pour pour le film
sincèrement dans quel état d'esprit tu
es ce soir céline très curieuse comme
tout le monde je crois
il ya beaucoup de cette cérémonie elle
est très particulière on n'a pas le
confort de faire fi du contexte
donc on est en responsabilité par
rapport à ce contexte voilà je suis
c'est le plus gros suspens depuis très
longtemps je crois
et voilà que aux hits et intérêts
excitation enthousiasme ce qui nous
caractérise globalement je crois
adèle céline leur appel à l'instance et
un contexte très particulier dans quel
état d'esprit tu es toi ce soir je pense
que c'est important qu'on soit là et
je sais pas on est un peu tendue je
dirais quand même est content de pouvoir
représenter bas notre cinéma et nos
idées en fait voilà passion quand même
qu'il ya un mouvement qui est en marche
aujourd'hui et tu disais c'est important
pour vous d'être là de d'accompagner ce
mouvement
oui en tout cas de montrer qu'il existe
parce qu'il ya des mouvements et des
contrôles mouvement on va dire et donc
nous on essaie de montrer la vitalité de
notre vision du monde enfin te dire
qu'elle est politique et qu'en même
temps elle est inventive
voilà et quelle et aimante en fait ça
veut dire qu'elle laisse la place aux
gens sachent rien vous êtes tout
ensemble c'était important justement
avec béatrice que là aussi de d'être
réunis ce soir je m'adresser la
productrice
pour nous c'est très important d'être
tout ensemble ce livre bien sûr mais on
a toujours été toutes ensemble de toute
façon il n'y avait pas d'autre
alternative
mais il ya des images qui y voit là qui
d'un coup sont comment dire comme
dynamisé par des contacts
donc c'est surtout ce que les gens font
cette image qui comptait c'est pas à
nous accompagner moment à un moment
c'est aux autres d'accompagner les
mouvements
voilà merci beaucoup très bonne soirée
merci